what it was
[Music]
is it a bug what is it there don't even
look kill oh they look like no squeeze
what what's going on these are gummies
what kind of gummies I think it looks
like a little squid or like cthulhu's
face it looks like a graham cracker but
it's pretty gummy
[Music]
this wasn't how I was expecting this to
go picking nature I like Brianna's come
because I'm like naturally 80 wait how
did you do that
oh you're like I was gonna be sweet and
that touches your tone you're just like
holy [ __ ] what isn't that bad sure he
made so much of a fuss
he's not that bad I could hear him like
mother I thought it would be like coffee
or chocolate or caramel booze neither of
those melted licorice I don't know what
that is but it's definitely salty salt
makes flavors more intense and black
Irish is an awful flavor so it's just a
more intense awful flavor tastes like
sour pepper like salted black licorice
so it's too terrible flavors but again
I'm a savory type of person but when I
was four years old I threw up black
licorice at a park and I haven't even
had cents so the more you chew it it
definitely like tastes a little bit
better
everything was like whoa world Red Alert
red alert something's happening you love
it I like it yeah I could eat the whole
thing why would you take this
[Music]